c'est fort
bonjour à tous je suis ses coûts et le
texte est qu aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du conseil départemental
alors c'est quoi le conseil
départemental comme nous l'avons vu dans
un épisode précédent de ses coûts et
depuis les élections de mars 2015
le conseil général s'appelle désormais
le conseil départemental
mais ce n'est pas le seul changement
dorénavant ce conseil aura une parité
parfaite d'élus femmes et d'élus homme à
la réunion il y a ainsi 25 femmes et 25
hommes qui y siègent et quelles sont les
missions du conseil départemental
ils organisent les actions du
département dans le cadre de ses
compétences principales dans le domaine
du social de l'agriculture et de la
forêt des collèges ou des routes ils
votent les rapports qui sont préparées
par les services administratifs pour
essentiellement financer le
fonctionnement et les investissements
voté lors de l'adoption du budget il
peut également présenter des mentions
qui sont transmises au préfet et au
gouvernement mais comment fonctionne un
conseil départemental
il se réunit au moins une fois par
trimestre à l'initiative de la
présidente les réunions se font toujours
avec un ordre du jour déterminé afin que
les élus puissent s'y préparer lors de
ces réunions
il faut que la majorité absolue des
membres soit atteinte pour que ces
délibérations soient valables il est
donc très important que les élus soient
présents à ces assemblées
l'absentéisme est donc très faible et
comment les élus se prépare tu as eu
réunion au moins deux jours avant chaque
réunion l'ensemble des élus reçoit un
rapport sur tous les points qui seront
évoqués cela leur permet de préparer
leurs questions remarques ou objections
en parfaite connaissance de cause et
donc de voter ou non les projets
présentés la présidente at-elle d'autres
pouvoirs aux missions bien entendu les
présidents et ce qu'on appelle l'organe
exécutif du département elle prépare et
exécute les décisions du conseil
départemental
elle dirige les différents services du
département et gère le domaine du
département elle exécute les décisions
budgétaires et signe les contrats et
conventions au nom du département elle
doit aussi une fois par an présenté en
séance plénière avec les 49 autres élus
au conseil la situation du département
la présidente représente également
le département lors des visites
officielles à titre protocolaire et
républicains et elle fait cela tout seul
naturellement nous une seule personne ne
pourrait pas faire tout cela elle est
assistée dans son travail
non seulement par l'ensemble des
services du département mais aussi par
la commission permanente au sein de
laquelle sont élus les vice présidents
le président peut ainsi déléguer
l'exercice d'une partie de ses fonctions
à ses vice présidents le président et
les vice-présidents forment ensemble ce
qu'on appelle le bureau
c'est un peu comme un gouvernement mais
au niveau d'un département d'el
président du conseil départemental
peut-il remplir d'autres fonctions bien
entendu il peut par exemple être un élu
municipal
mais certaines fonctions lui sont
légalement interdites comme être
également président d'un conseil
régional maire membre de la commission
européenne j'espère que vous avez bien
compris ce qu'est le conseil
départemental et la fonction de son
président à bientôt pour un nouvel
épisode
je